I know woman she had a baby and she was
in the early 50s 60s and she had it
naturally totally unexpected
when a baby's not a promise but it's
like what happens the next decade you're
going to be sick
school around there's that's what I
think about as well
you know it's not just about if your
body can carry it because having to say
that when you go into if you take your
church at the age if you take your child
into the school and you're going to be
looked at as a grandparent or the great
grandparent well this hell who's your
granny now that's my mom yeah and people
need to think about having children late
because I knew a woman and she had a
child late and it's only and her
daughter got married and left that her
daughter told her how scared she was all
of her life their mom was gonna die
exactly because my mother and she really
thought yeah growing up and their mum
didn't know that